foreign
in Cleveland Ohio what's up Terence
how you doing good how are you man
I've done better hanging in there oh man
what's up
so I'm currently faced with the idea of
Silent bankruptcy
um I currently have about 70 000 in debt
I make about 20 000 a year
I've been working for about a year now I
was in a nursing home for a year before
that and um as of now I just had a
recent
uh bad incident my car was stolen back
in August and um with the repairs I've
defaulted on my uh
car note I actually got two months
deferred already
and now I have to pay a large deductible
to get it from the mechanic and I'm
still you know faced with the uh with
the car payments
which is more than half of my monthly
income right now and I've been
considering following chapter seven to
remove a lot of my debts and try to
start over because it's to the point
where I'm not able to save anything at
the end of the month yeah Terence can I
ask you what are you doing for a job
right now
I'm a custodian okay and did you did I
hear you right you're making about 20
000.
yeah okay and then you said you were did
I hear you say you were in a nursing
home
I was yeah okay do you have any physical
limitations right now that would uh keep
you from doing
any other type of work than being a
custodian
um well I have heart disease
um minor neurological deficiencies like
my endurance is very low okay I have to
extend my energy twice as much to do
normal functions is the custodial job I
don't want to assume but is it a
physical job obviously on your feet a
lot and doing a lot of physical labor
I mean yeah but I work in my own pace I
got employed through this organization
called vocational guidance and it's
pretty much geared towards disabled
persons like myself okay uh another
couple quick questions here
um
how much how much do you owe to get that
car from the mechanic what would be the
fee you got to pay to get it back
one thousand dollars a thousand dollars
and what would you say the car is worth
versus what you owe on it
it's worth about 20 and I owe for 35.
I'm sorry you broke up you owe what
oh 35 oh 35 000 and the car is only
worth about 20 000. okay all right
uh
uh the the reason I went that direction
John and Terence the reason I'm asking
you about what you're doing what your
physical limitations are
um is because I even though you have
limitations and I know you went through
an organization that's trying to help
you out
man I I'm willing to stake my entire
name and reputation on the fact that you
should be making and you can be making
way more than twenty thousand which
would help us in this financial
situation to come up with a thousand
dollars to get the car then we could
sell the car uh get a smaller loan it's
the only time we recommend loans uh
maybe from a credit union and to pay off
the rest of the loan and then start
fresh but one of the things we've got to
do is get you into a place where you can
make more income but not have all the
physical exertion because you do have
some physical limitations and and I want
to try to help you on that we may not be
able to solve it all on this call but I
at least want to put that out to you so
that you have a mindset that you don't
have to look at chapter seven to get out
of this mess do you understand what I'm
saying I know you feel like that's the
only option you have left
how does that hit you how do you push
back if there's some pushback something
that John and I don't know
it's been a very depressing you know
dealing with it all and I never even
considered filing bankruptcy ever in my
life sure so Terence uh filing for
bankruptcy if we look at the data
um
has a lot of external consequences
besides money and you're feeling it
right now right it feels like it's going
to be this big freedom in this big
release and there is a release to it but
man
what it does to your psyche what it does
to your ability to navigate certain
things moving forward it's just such a
burden it's it's very similar to divorce
I'll never recommend somebody get
divorced that's a decision someone's got
to make on their own and I don't ever
recommend that somebody file for
bankruptcy simply because I know the
downstream consequences are so heavy
sometimes it's your only option Dave's
talked about it he's he did it
um and he is probably one of the last in
lines to say hey he went and developed a
plan so that nobody ever has to go
through that right
um
I've spent my career up until I I joined
Ramsey Solutions working with
people with learning exceptionalities
and with special needs
did they Place does this agency place
you in a place where they said this is
all you can do
because right now when I look at the
wages even at minimum wage places are
paying double minimum wage in certain
places they're paying a lot more than
twenty thousand dollars a year to work
fast food right now or to drive Uber and
I'm thinking I'm trying to think of a
couple of places that you could work and
then get another job driving around
where you could just listen to music or
listen to podcasts or talk on the phone
and if you have those days where you're
just
worn out
um you can stay at home you don't have
to work that shift if it's Uber or if
it's ubereats or if it's one of those
you know Lyft or anything like that
my question for you is this
instead of
um just saying all I'm ever going to do
is be able to do twenty thousand dollars
a year do you have a mentor or a friend
or someone who will walk alongside you
that's outside of the agency that you
trust that you said hey we got a figure
I got to make more money and I need your
help looking at jobs applying for jobs
going to interview with jobs would you
be willing to walk alongside is there
somebody else that would help you with
that or is the agency all you got
not at the moment I think they're
literally all I have right now I haven't
um
even consider you know
trying to find other
um
like people of that kind of bird to talk
to okay well Terence I I want to
challenge you on something because I
John and I know you can get out of this
I know you can and we want you to borrow
our belief if you just got John and I
today I'm telling you Terence yes you
have the physical limitations but John
is right we're talking Walmart and and
Target late shifts
you can make as much as 18 20 22 dollars
an hour not only that
um Kroger just announced I don't know if
you had but I've given you ideas to
where you go wait a second the world is
much bigger than this agency just
placing me somewhere where they have a
relationship because more money changes
your life dramatically am I right or am
I wrong
you're right I mean I want you just for
a second to imagine making twenty
dollars an hour
how would that change your life
I wouldn't worry so much come on man
you'll be able to get that car out of
the mechanic pretty quick
and and John's right I mean that what
people are paying listen and can I tell
you this I want to paint a bigger
picture
Walmart Target just two big companies
they are also giving tuition
reimbursement to where not only you work
and making more money you could take the
next chapter in your life and get
qualified for something and they're
going to reimburse you so you got to
know there are more possibilities for
you and you can get the car out of the
mechanic and you can pay the debt off
you can walk through this and we're
going to walk through this with you
let's let's give you Financial Peace
University we're going to give to you a
full year of that and I want to give you
the book uh Dave's book he sold six
million copies something like that and
Counting Total Money Makeover if I give
that to you will you promise to read it
yes I do do you believe Terence that you
can come out of this
yeah
I
let me take one step myself let me take
one step below what Ken's saying
you've been told you're less than
haven't you
I have ever since I got sick and
suffered a traumatic brain injury and
all of that stuff yeah that's right
you've been told she's been very shocked
you've been told you're broken you've
been told you're less than you've been
told you go over there and Ken and I are
both calling bull crap on that we
believe in you more than you do and I
want you to believe in yourself as much
as Ken and I do
stay on the line we're going to get you
these tools in hand
and man trust us there is light on the
other side of this thing now we're so
proud of you brother somebody needs you
to show up and be the best version of
Terence that the world has ever seen
that's where we want you to get to